hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John I'm dressed nice today because
God instructed me to there's a behind
the scenes a BTS or should I say b vs no
mm-hmm
whew thor ragnarok uploaded by marble oh
really
damn yeah yeah they did you know blade
and infinity war Sin City believe a
history of violence Ghost World American
Splendor wanted a lot man kick-ass no
I'm talk--i the exact same my dear Vince
Vaughn Ragnarok is trying to have war
attitude
rocks a new cycle in the light of the
world it's the destruction of the old
and the revisited surprise me such fun
the way that I've approached this is to
rebuild in a new way character story you
know different cultures different
weapons different cast or characters to
work or give you a different energy
Thor's in a crisis he never went back to
Asgard to claim him from he wanted
adventure
when we pick him up he's at the end of
this search for himself we survive this
trip you know I want you to take people
on a ride and do some comedy into it an
adventure that keeps people laughing
along the way but it also has its peak
to color in the stuff that it gets
people excited he's a fighter you know
weirdly that kind of gets me more
excited than a lot of the latest
trailers I've seen sort of like a
reaction part I know we weren't like
you're like oh hearing like the insight
yeah that all translates incredibly well
just in the marketing yeah one
especially the recent trailers we've
seen have been more international so
those are more action heavy and it was a
night it's like I haven't seen that shot
where Hulk comes in and he's like yes in
a while and it hit me when I saw this I
was like oh the humor yeah enter because
you know you can't do that as much for
international trailer yeah this got me
back excited just to see the fun there
blam - this I heard he let the actors
improvise yeah a lot of scenes he was
talking about just making a film that's
really fun but of course having the
spectacle as well and it really dawned
on me the production design in every
scene like when Loki is chained up and
like he's wearing green in the rooms
green yeah yeah I noticed that a lot of
the time the color palettes would change
you know when the colors are really
strong in this yeah and it really hit me
in that shot where they're in what looks
like a big junk heap and they like catch
him in the net and I wasn't gonna die
yeah I just got like a Star Wars vibe I
was like oh you got like a bunch of
different looking extraterrestrial
characters and this like brightly
colored but still like broad world scape
you know and it did make it feel like a
bigger part of the more sort of space
off or a side of the Marvel Universe
we're getting with you know the
guardians of the galaxy and now this I
think what I really took away from this
was what Chris Hemsworth was saying
about where Thor is currently at because
I was thinking about you know I like the
idea of changing the tone and changing
the style to make it more humorous more
fun-filled adventure and then I was
thinking like but that it seems a little
bit of a
drastic difference from the previous
Thor movies or even his appearances in
like The Avengers movies you know where
he is more of a self sir takes himself
seriously yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
he was talking about how Thor's at this
point his life were and Mark Ruffalo is
chiming in to saying how he didn't go
back to Asgard to take up the throne
he's looking for adventure he wants to
have fun and and he's just at the end of
sort of like discovering himself exactly
so the tone that's being struck up in
the marketing reflects what they're
saying about where Thor is at so it
feels in tune with where Thor is as I
I've been thinking it's just the world
and the director providing a different
tone and style but it's different when
I'm like oh it's actually reflecting
where Thor really is at beyond just the
movie you know given I'm getting out
here well yeah it seems like I like the
movie itself and the character both
gonna embody this sort of new vigor or
something you know a new attitude a new
and I think that's what Thor needs again
because the past two installments like
they've always had humor but they've
kind of oscillated back and forth
between like big stakes battle also
there's some humor over here
occasionally and this movie looks like
it's really gonna synthesize the two
that way that that gives the tone
something unified and solid well even
looking back at Thor you know in the
first one he's a fish out of water what
makes it so funny is he's the god of
thunder but like no one everyone's like
dude just chill out and that's the part
and that's what movie I like the most
yeah I honestly don't remember the dark
world all too well but even in like the
Avengers movies you know like yeah he
has his crazy powers but he is that guy
who takes himself really serious and
it's nice to see a more loosened up
Chris Hemsworth because Chris Hemsworth
is amazing and comedy funny comedic
timing is incredible so I'm excited to
see this all infused in Mark Ruffalo too
and this seems like another step in the
right direction especially because you
know like any Thor movies gonna have an
apocalyptic or a huge stake scenario and
I feel like making this one perhaps one
of the more humorous series would be a
good name for them I'm wondering how
hella though will be handled yeah you
know with everything we're hearing at
this film being more funny more
adventurous exciting what is
due to the bill what does that do to the
villain yeah well make the villain
threatening will we actually feel
threatened or will she just be like
amusing
you know she gonna have humor in her
care yeah that's what I do I never
concerned about it yeah and what they
gotta make her funny yeah yeah I mean
she definitely got attitude from the few
because we only see like the same couple
shots of her for the most part yeah I
feel like she's definitely got attitude
she plays seems to be playing it like
somebody who enjoys being the goddess of
death yes yeah I am curious about that
too for sure and that's probably what
we'll you know make or break this movie
in the overall scope of the Marvel
Universe
I guess because those villains man but I
do she look I mean what he said but um
but I get it yeah
yeah is it but how does go the
traditional is but um but um yeah once
you and I went but um well some people
don't that's an iMovie say that the
comedy the comedy drum roll the comedy
rimshot is that is you know there are a
couple of variations comedy rimshot but
um that's the kind of humor but hoping
Thor Ragnarok has less mood but humor
but scratch it's the best social
experiment because no matter where you
yell it somebody will call back
buttscratcher you Marco Polo for the
Millennials you have an actual point you
were making I totally interrupted you
with the but um Shh Oh or we could break
that down boy I get a vibe this is just
a personal feeling but I feel like Cate
Blanchett is probably gonna rock that
role I just feel like I like the footage
I've seen of her and I love her
performances typically she's a new face
to see in a movie like this and it's not
like they're covering her in full
intensive makeup like they have with
some of the previous villains I think
there's at least potential but I am a
little worried you know let's find out
it's two hours and ten minutes yeah yeah
it's almost three hours round up
I mean you know you factor the trailers
and you know free movie trivia and stuff
like that whatever they show it all
counts so part of the red side and then
however long that hypothetical
post-credits stinger ends up being I
like to show up only for the
post-credits - yeah can I pay for this
I wanted popcorn during the credits at
night like two hours and eight minutes
in profit nod you want to return your
tickets now uh-huh I'd rather just see
the post-credits is the subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell follow - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram go check out our patreon
become a patron eject today decide dress
now flat shirt
giant basketballs yours